Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Unforgiving: A Northern Hymn
Now this is an indie horror game, but it actually looks very, very good
with fluid animations and cool art styles
And supposedly something- *Girl gasping for breath in the background* Oh
*Gasping for breath in game*
Can't breathe...
*girl gasping for breath*
Am I supposed to not be seeing anything here?
Ooh...
Did I die?
I just got into this game, I'd rather not be dead.
*Gasping ceases, character is heavily breathing*
Oh, hello.
Oh no
This is the Forest all over again!
I've washed- I've washed up on the beach
Ohh.
That's cool though.
Hello...?
Ah, no. Ah god!
It's not shake-powered!
'Must find help.' So yeah, this game-
It's in early alpha so it's not actually done, but
From what I saw, it looked pretty dang good for being just an alpha
But it is dark as hell
Hooo, I can't see anything!
HELLO?! Is anyone on this abandoned island probably full of monsters that wants to- help me.
Oh, okay, I can't see shiiit!
Alright so, just to set the mood a little bi- *Bug flies by in game*
-Fucking god dammit!
(Mr. bug please leave mark alone...... jeez)
Stop!
Alright, just to set the mood a little bit
I'm going to- uh, not "shout into the forest"
Randomly- I have no idea where I'm going.
I have no idea where I'm supposed to be going
I-I'm seeing like the outlin-
*weird noises in the background*
D'okay...
There seems to bl- I- There's something, like blocking out the entirity of the moon
Which makes me think that I'm next to a mountain of some sort
But if I could just get around it...
*a voice saying something about following the path* Hi- Okay, alright!
Mark makes a weird noise
I'm sorry, what was that? Could you repeat it, I don't give a fuck.
Okay, alright. Thank you, have a nice day!
Alright, cool!
That was nice. That was nice!
The way they do that thing where they... talk to me in my-
Ohhh! Light!
Oh, good. Maybe this can reclaim a bit of my sanity here.
Hello? I finally found a light
Oh good. Matches, finally.
How in the world- Yeah, shake everything you find.
Ah, so many matches.
Unlimited even, right?!
Not a, not a set number... I hope.
Woah.
The fuck is that?
..Alright
Is that a giraffe?
Is that a baboo giraffe?
Ohh, it's... adorable.
Oh, It's adorable!
Ohh, it's got blood on it
Ah, that makes it twice as adorable. Oh!
Ohhhhkay
Aaaalright
Just gotta skidaddly- Euh.
Boy.
Maybe I shouldn't skidaddly.
Yeesh.
Is there any reason I should drop the match other than it's gonna burn my fingers?
I don't even know where I came from
Did I fall off of the boat?
Oh, I see another light over there
Okay, that's a good sign!
Unless it's like a very bad sign because it's leading me into the trap of death
I don't like that trap.
Bad trap..
Okay- So there's nothing here, though
But I seem to be going the right way, question mark?
'Cause if there's-
What was that?
Okay, alright. Didn't hear anything! No, nothing happened!
What are you guys talking about?
Nothing happened.
There's nothing here
-Happening. No squeakies!
No squonkos!
No! I don't hear anything.
Nothing.
Nope! That ain't nothing.
No, if I say it's nothing, it ain't nothing!
Ah! I don't hear nothing.
What are you talking bout?
Huh? I don't know what- *Dramatic music* I should toss this before I burn my fingers
Ahhhh, hang on everybody. I'm just gonna sit here listening to the whole nothing going on here.
While I just... fetch a new match out of my matchbox, here.
Alright.
Ah, going up my own way.
*Dum sound* Boy, my stomach is rumbly tonight!
Always did sound like big bass drum hits.
Oh, boy, can you not do that...
Ohh!
Oh, you! Always leading me into underground caverns!
Mines, and what-not.
Alright. Good thing I didn't light any of these on the way or that would've been a pain in the butt.
Okay, alright, *Mumbling*
*Clears throat*
*Loud footsteps*
Uh... Now you're gonna go quiet?
Now you're gonna go quiet. NOW the game's gonna go quiet.
When I'm already in the midst of uh...
...The road to hell.
It's gonna go quiet. Wow.
I'm just gonna stand here in perpetual darkness for just a moment as I relight a match
I hate this mechanic by the way, it's very terrifying
I don't even get to- b- b to blow the matches out.
Let's start a- Oh, fudge...
Oh, thank you. Good. I-
For a second there, I thought I wouldn't have been able to keep going down into the depth of hell.
Yeah, this is a goooood idea.
What part of, like...
*character inhaling and exhaling*
what part of like coming out of a boat accident
or how the hell I got in the ocean-
*weird noises in the background*
hey you know what, maybe I should just turn back
that would be *grunt* that would be great
if I could do that
*mumbling* I wasn't a brave boy
okay, alright, please tell me this place isn't filled with spiders
*mumbling* cuz that's nice
what's that?
okay
oH!
oh good!
I can make these float in midair
that- that's awfully nice
don't know what are to
some kind of ruuunes of some sort
I like me a good rune!
*weird naked creature running past*
*gasp* was that a naked streaker
was that a streaker??
was that a streaker in the middle of this god damn mine??
was there someone running naked in this god damn mine?!
cuz that's something that I will not stand for, okay?!
put on my sneaking shoes so I feel a little-
okay so I just burned my fingers off, alright, that's fine
that one lasted a lot less longer than the other ones I've had
okay, alright, moving on!
who's naked?
it's okay, come on, I'm a nudist myself, so you can just, ya know-
depend on me
*weird static noise*
that's uhm...
someone connecting to the internet from the 1994's?
that was a good joke me, thanks
oh boy
Oh
alright then I'm just gonna keep moving forward
Cause this point any clever and witty things I can say--
*honking noise*
Are gonna lead to something like THAT
Children singing in the darkness
You have something to say to me?
You have some hidden message that you want to tell me little kid?
*match fizzing out*
Nothing?
*Creepy noises and ominous music*
just gonna
keep going
alright, moving along
Ah, that's nice music
Ah yeah that's good...
okay, alright what are you doing
what are you doing
*GASP*
hi are you naked too? oh I'm very naked myself
Alright
You still there?
You gonna talk to me-- *thud* *gasps*
what the fuck just happened?
*still gasping*
goodnight
hi-yee
oh hi oh yeah nice ass, okay, alright
you BIT me?
*mark making weird mocking noises*
Jesus
Well you're not going to come here and apologize? No you're just gonna walk off?
I'm naked
I don't care
okay fine... fuuu you
what is this
what kind of underground mine is this?
Why does it have a dedicated railway system leading into nothing
and are you just trying to show of with your nudity or--
alright you know what?
I think I'm finding that uh
I don't care
So how about you take your whisperings and shove it--
oh
Oh oh hey
oh God oh
oh hi oh boy
you too huh?
oh nice boob bite
holy shit
oh no is that what happens after you get bit?
I thought that was like
oh man
I thought that was just like
my match just went out on its own okay
check my arm
oh my arm is not looking good
OH NO I'm going to turn into a tree!
great
oh boy... oh boy..
Is it- is it still bad? Is it bad? I- yeah, it's bad.
Okay, it's bad
*incomprehensible whispering in game*
Okayy, alright then.. That's good advice
I don't know what you're trying to tell me,
But you're pointing in a direction, holding out your hand
I dunno what that means, but it's probably a clue
I'm just gonna keep following the tracks...
'Cause I don't think I can go anywhere to the left or the right
It's just a solid wall- yep, it's a solid wall
Alright then. Don't mind me, just gonna check my arm
How's my arm? Ahhh, bad
I don't wanna hurt your mom! I just wanted help!
I fell off a boat.. My phone don't work
What the hell is going on?
euughh.. I've got that disease from Game of Thrones
hi
Oh no.. Oh no!
Ohhh go-ha-od no
Ahhh.. This is unpleasant.
Ah, this is just an unpleasant experience
I'm gonna demand my money back when I get out of this haunted house.
Hmmmmph
Okay, yeah, let's- *whispering in game* - oh.
*incomprehensible whispering in game continues*
Wha..
*more incomprehensible whispering*
I'm not gonna fit through there!
What are you talking about?!
*even more incomprehensible whispering*
Yeah, I can't fit through there, so that ain't gonna happen
nOOOOO
I've gotta light the baby on fire?!
Oh.. welp, I don't have a lot of time, so ya know what, I'm
Yah, I'm sorry
Sorry 'bout this. I'm sorry about this!
*mother in game begging, incomprehensible*
*baby noise*
I don't WANT to do it!
I don't want to light your baby on fire! Are you even alive...?
I'm sorry
*mother crying*
Alright, you know what? I'm just gonna get a new one
'cause, I.. I-I don't I just..
Is there any other option than this?! There's no other option
I literally can't...
There's no other way! Could I talk to little girl over here? I don't think so
*mother incomprehensible in background* uughh..
I don't have a lot of time to debate this, my arm is getting woRSE
It's getting worse- okay, I gotta gah I gotta ahh I'm sorry, lady
*baby crying in background* Ah man, I'm sorry
Ahh this is like the worst thing I could possibly do
Auuhh, I'm an asshole
*mother screaming in agony, baby crying*
Auuughh..
Gahhhdd-ja that's not gooood
Euughh
Eughh, that is unpleasant..
Hoa, man.
Ah, man..
What the fudge...
Oh boy
Where am I goin'? Am I out?
Did I make it through?
Can I- can I just turn into a tree and take my punishment for this?
*echoey footsteps in game, ominous music continues*
Alright, okay- wooah
I thought I saw a head in the wall
Wouldn't have been too.. surprised considering everything else I've been-
Ooooh I've made it out? Ohhh.. okay
I thought that was a bunch of heads on a spike
*Mark mumbling something about a forest*
*monsterous sounds in game*
Ha.. Alright, ya know, you could leave me alone, and also go fuck yourself
That'd be nice, too, great, okay
*Mark mumbling again*
*sniFF*
Alright, I'm gonna get help just in time for them to see me turn into a tree
*monstrous sounds coming from behind*
I DON'T WANT ANY
*Monsterous footsteps get louder and moves to the right* OH- HEY! OHH MY GOD
OHHH MY GOD OH MY GOD OH MY GOD WHAT WAS THAT?
I DIDN'T EVEN SEE WHAT IT WAS
OOOOKAY
*brisk footsteps in game*
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAAAAAT?
WHAT THE FUCK WAS STIP-STEPPIN ALL OVER THESE WOODS?
THESSEE WOODS
Okay, I don't like that, don't repeat that on me
Woah, okay. Just gonna assume that it's.. not following me
Oh boy, okay, alright
Just gotta keep- ah, keep swimmin'
That's what I should've done, I never should've come to this island
Should've just kept swimmin'
Oh boy..
*another sniFF*
Oh, what's this? What's this I see?
What's this? Ah, somethin' ta light
Okay, alright then, can I light it? Noooo
Alright then, fine.
Into the road
What? Do I just jump into the ocean? Is that gonna help me?
Oh god, I see it over there.
I'm not gonna be able to get over th- woah, hey! Well, that looks modern!
.. How is my arm doin'?
Ahugh...
I've seen- it's.. I think it's getting better, I think it's getting better
You know what, I think- I think it's actually getting better
Oh good! A fan of My Little Pony lives here.
Greeeeaaatt..
'Rune Svensson and Henrik Anderson'
Okay.. ROONI
*incomprehensible mumbling in game*
'Sacrificial rituals of the old days'- Oh!
Heh, my kind of people live here!
Ah, okay
If they're in a ritualistic sacrifice, then hey, buuhh
tHE PARTY IS HERE
*character is shot back* Oh, fuck!
Character in game: Hey, hey *screaming, rustling in the background*
*monsterous sound*
*monsterous footsteps walking away*
oookayy...
Alllriighhtt then
I, uh..
My timing could use some... ya know..
Help.
.. Oh boy..
*faint rustling sounds*
Don't mind me, just gonna light up this place
*match sounds*
Ah..
Ah, okay.. Alright..
Well, the party came and went..
*splat* woooahhhh..
Hooooookaaaay
That's, uh, good day, sir
Thanks for letting me use your home
I'll just take the back door
Alrighty then
I don't know where I'm going, but I...
I have a funny feeling that I'm going to meet something in the woods very soon that's gonna
Rip my entire body out of my ass
Ah boy...
If it could just, please, while it's turning me inside out,
Be quick about it, ya know.. Try to make it a painless, ya know..
death..
This is an unforgiving hymn indeed..
How's my arm doin'? Aha, it's finee
It's fine, I'll walk it off, don't worry
*screaming in the distance*
Heh, he's laughin'
*screaming intensifies*
*scream cuts off*
Ha, he stopped laughin', the joke must've gotten old..
Haha, alright.. okay, then..
*slight thunder in background*
Oh boy..
*rain sounds*
Ookay, okay, okay okay..
Alright, so, for those of you watching at home,
I think- I think we've made it, I think everything's gonna be okay now- oh..
... I don't have matches anymore because of the rain, that's good
Couldn't see anything anyway
Oh, that's- that's illuminating, thank you for that
oh boy..
*gun shots?*
oH OKAY ALRIGHT *ROAR*
WOAHHH ALRIGHT I'M RUNNIN'
OHH HE'S RIGHT BEHIND ME
OOHH WHERE DO I GO?
Lightning, please, thank you, Thor, could you please kick it up a NOTCH
THOR, I NEED A LITTLE MORE LIGHT, HERE
THOORR
GODDAMMIT, THOR
*character wheezing from running*
You're the GOD OF THUNDER, THOR
JUST HELP ME- ooohh fuck
*dramatic music*
hEY.. HI..
*dramatic music continues*
*monster noise*
*even more dramatic music*
ooookkayyyyy
I am a changed man..
Eugh... I have seen darkness and
know it to be evil
So, I am just going to, ah..
.. Say that this was really well done and I like that concept art by the way
I'm just a tree? Like, that's how I turn out to be?
That's my pose?
If I'm gonna turn into a tree, I'm gonna get a better pose than hah
I'm gonna get a pose like: *kiss sound* ooooo
And I'm gonna get a pose like: uhhh
That would be the worst pose in the world
*Sad excuse for a British accent* And here, the world's stupidest tree
Oh, the fad of the dab only lasted three years and yet, here it stands as a testament to its eternal stupidness
Here we go: and then it's just me,
.. crying.. forever, with bloOD
So, that was Unforgiving: A Northern Hymn
This looks really good, it's got a lot of potential here
It really built up some creep-factor
And I love the fact that, for the most time,
You didn't even get to see the horrible monstrosity until right at the end
When it ran away from the crying- whatever it was
And, it was just cool
That was really well-done because it made it terrifying 'cause it's like
I gotta keep runnin', I can't stop to look
There ain't no two ways about it
If I look, I'm dead, I'm not going for it
And it built that up really well, and also, I had the really, intriguing and horrifying choice of burning the "baby"
of a mom who's been turned into a tree, and it's gonna heppen to me,
and then some naked people, that just throws in for some fan service
But, either way, that was pretty good, so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think of this in the comments below
And also, help get this green-lit, and it doesn't cost anything, you just gotta vote for it, so
Thank you, again, and as always..
I will see you... in the next video!
BA-BYEEE!
*outro music*